روسيا وايران كلاهما ترزحان تحت العقوبات
الاولى بسبب حربها على اوكرانيا والثانيه
بسبب برنامجها النووي امر نقتضى بالضروره
تكثيف التعاون بينهما على ما يبدو وعلى
راس القائمه التعاون العسكري ايران تزود
روسيا بالمسيرات والاسيرات تزويران
بالصواريخ بالمقاتلات اخر فصول هذا
التعاون المكثف ما نقلته صحيفه تايم تايم
عن تقرير استخباراتيه افاد استعداد روسيا
لتزويد ايران بطائره سوخوي المقاتله من
تراث السوق 35 في المستقبل القريب التقرير
والاستخباراتيه ذكر ان الصفقه قد تشمل
اربعه 24 طائره سوء 35 التي تعتبر احدى
اخطر خمسه مقاتلات على مستوى العالم وفق
تصنيف مجله مجله الامريكيه نتعارف معكم
مشاهدينا على ابرز مميزات المقاتله 35
الملقب بملكه قاتلات دخلت الخدمه في الجيش
الروسي عام 2014 وبلغ عددها في القوات
الجوف الفضائيه نحو مئه مقاتله سوق 35
طائره من الجيل الرابع المعزز تمتلك
مواصفاتها من الجيل الخامس تتميز بقدره
فائقه على المناوره السريعه ومزوده بنظام
القياده الرقمي للمعلوماتيه ويبلغ طولها
نحو 22 مترا اما سرعتها فتصل الى
2400 كيلو متر في الساعه على ارتفاع 11
كلم بالنسبه للمدى فاسو 35 يبلغ مداها
ثلاثه الاف و600 كم وقد يصل اقصى مدى لها
الى اربعه الاف كيلو متر في حال تم اضافه
خزانات وقود خارجيه المقاتله الروسيه
مزوده باسلحه ذكيه حديثه تطيح لها الرسم
وتدمير عدد من الاهداف الجويه والارضيه في
وقت واحد وبدقه كبيره
[موسيقى]
التقرير واضح ان المعلومات الاستخباراتيه
اشارت الى ان الطيارين ايرانيين كانوا
بالفعل يستخدمون الطائرات للتدريب لكن دون
الخوض في التفاصيل واشنطن اشارات الى ان
هناك تعاونا عسكريا متناميا بين ايران
وروسيا خاصه منذ سنه روسيا حربها على
اوكرانيا في فبراير الماضي واثمر هذا
التعاون عن تزويد طهران
1700 الطائره مسيره هجوميه حتى الان
تحدثنا كثيرا عن مسيرات الايرانيه وتخطط
لتزويدها بالثلاث مئه طائره اخرى في
المستقبل القريب وفقا لصحيفه متابعه في
هذه المعلومات تتهم اوكرانيا روسيا حاليا
باستخدام هذه الطائره الايرانيه لضرب
اهداف المدنيه ومنشات لانتاج الطاقه في
اوكرانيا وقد نفذ ايران مرارا تزويد موسكو
بالمسيرات قبل ان تؤكد مصادر مطلعه في
نوفمبر الماضي انها زودت روسيا بعدد من
الطائرات المسيره فعلا لكن قبل بدء موسكو
حربها ضد جارتها الغربيه
[موسيقى]